[Music]
you of course uh uh spent a lot of your
time working with the disney people
uh-huh now you've come out with this
movie i'm sure you're getting this
question a lot but i got to ask is it
are you welcome back at disney world now
if you went back to disney world where
they would say get out of here you may
not return you may not enter you shall
not pass
um yeah no uh
no so they did say no no they're fine i
love going i actually went recently um
with my friends uh matt prokop and sarah
highland and uh sarah's filmed an
episode of modern family there and so
they had like a foot in and they had
this club there called club 33 and you
have to be an exclusive member to get it
disneyland has an exclusive club inside
and it's just for i mean like no one uh
i couldn't go in there right no okay
all right
it's so like it's crazy there's a 20
year old just now i want to go so badly
right well i know the minute someone
says you can't go you want to go yeah
it's like spring break yeah not so much
uh
okay so so so it's this exclusive club
at disneyland and you've gone there and
what's so cool about it this club 33.
well obviously the exclusivity um and
it's like it's just really cool it's
like this lounge and like it's really
classic and it's a beautiful restaurant
but like i went and like super stoked to
be there but the one thing i actually
took a picture of was the bathroom stall
the toilet i brought a picture okay
let's see it's an angel what is that
that's the bathroom store that is like
that's barbie's toilet okay
right like that's pretty cool yeah so
you took that do they know that you've
taken a picture of their inner secret
chamber i don't think how they do yeah
they're dispatching now i'm banned yeah
no now most robots are headed this way
you know
destroy the one called hutchins um
james franco in the movie with you he
plays a very intense uh character he's
uh you know he's a he's criminal uh he's
got this amazing look in the movie uh
i didn't even know that it's crazy
because i didn't know that was him
until it was explained to me that that
is in fact james franco but that's just
it's funny because you look at that and
you go it looks funny like you guys
laugh at it but like his character is
done in a way that is so believable like
he's unbelievably incredible in the
movie and he was in that character all
the time he stuck he committed to the
cornrows and like the tan skin the whole
time oh yeah he had like all these
grungy tattoos and like dirt all over
his face i don't know if that was makeup
or just dirt on his fingers all the time
but he like kept the cornrows in the
entire dress
i for a charity event i did a show with
cornrows and a spray tan
and the cornrows hurt
incred it's unbelievably painful well i
bet they're like just pulling at your
hair they pull at it and they pull it
really tight and uh and and i was
screaming and crying screaming yeah that
was like before they even began i was
screaming
we have this is my look this is me
that was me
[Applause]
beautiful
i don't know why i was looking off into
the sunset
you think you're a bond girl
yes yes i do i was my fantasy as a child
and now again uh